cher collégienne est cher collégiens
j'espère que vous allez tous bien ainsi
que vos parents je sais que de rester à
la maison sans voir aux copines et
copains ne doit pas être simple tous les
jours mais j'espère que vous passer de
bons moments avec vous famille et que
vous arrivez à continuer à prendre le
département à coeur d'être à vos côtés
pendant cette période de confinement
certains par nouveaux n'ont pas la
chance d'avoir un ordinateur à la maison
c'est pourquoi le département a décidé
de prêter 1300 pc à toutes les familles
qui en ont besoin
il est essentiel que chacun ait les
mêmes chances pour suivre les cours
depuis la maison
cette opération est rendue possible
grâce au concours de l'éducation
nationale et de la poste
merci à vous merci aussi à la société
élevé ou de molsheim qui a offert au
département 50 pc pour les chaînes
les premières livraisons ont pu avoir
lieu ce mardi 7 avril à prévenir cher
collégiennes et collégiens
je sais qu'il y à beaucoup d'entre elles
et de solidarité entre vous et avec ceux
qui vous entourent
un grand merci aussi à tous vos
professeurs vous êtes tous formidables
le collège étant ouverts pour accueillir
les enfants des personnels soignants
on est une base logistique pour le
départ de ses ordinateurs c'est une
livraison qui a lieu surtout des
collèges du secteur de colmar et plus
largement l'ensemble du département pour
l'instant nous en avons une quarantaine
mais c'est quelque chose qui va se
généraliser puisque les établissements
vont aussi participer en utilisant le
matériel qui est mis à disposition au
sein des établissements se pouvait pas
me axes des remembrements numérique et
sur les téléphones c'est vrai que c'est
un peu difficile la tâche des devoirs
tout près des messages et tu peux parler
avec elle des élèves lequel les pros